previously on hand simulator how's
everyone's mental state do we want to do
anonymous Club yeah what is that I don't
know I don't this seems like a bad idea
how are you okay
oh hey guys hey is this just an AAA
meeting I think yeah I think this is
just like a VR Chad style hold my hand
wait hey hold my hand can you hear me
yeah hey this is so thrilling we should
do hand puppets okay Bob do you know
this one hang on wait for it is that how
it went your first time yeah yeah like
this right just right on the edge yeah
couldn't quite couldn't quite make it
happen wait you're not seeing this
you're not saying all this thing that
I'm seeing yeah yeah it's like that you
wanna see it's like for me yeah I want
to see yeah it's like so it's like that
right but instead of the way you were
doing it for me
it's just like cool this is uh this is
some content boys weights just staring
dead-eyed at you oh hey oh it's muted
Jesus Christ this is my favorite thing
we've done so far today nope I'll
your mouth movers yeah I've got the
press V for a very long time so you guys
probably heard me talk no yeah
you're just island mark talking games -
your mouth moves I like the hand
position that you're holding Oh am I
still doing yeah I'm doing looking at my
hands dead eyes no cheek muscles
laughter that makes it terrifies you
guys like my bra this is what I wear
under my Santa suit every time you know
where's the rest of your sadness - I
thought we had a dress code for this
well I'm just saying I I thought this
was the real us I mean on the outside
we're Santa but on the inside I just
feel I'm still thin well I mean I'm
Santa - I'm just a different different
type of see I got creative and my Santa
suit is so long that it's addressed Wow
so I'm a Sant her you know wearing pants
that's what he just distress you don't
wear your promise you never listen can
you wear can you wear leggings but it's
not that kind of dress no okay that's
the point of what I was saying okay I'm
sorry yeah well you keep saying you're
sorry and then you keep doing it so well
you know it's half sorry I wanted to
talk about the main problem that we've
been running into that no I feel no one
is talking about mm-hmm that yeah you
know Chanukah is getting in the way of
the mall Santa experience I'm not
there's nothing wrong with Hanukkah
there's nothing wrong I saying that in
anyway but in the mall that's her
territory and I feel like it's being
tripped on so uh this is your solution
to keep it out of the mall to move ha a
car to move Christmas wait why would we
move worse miss Christmas what I feel
like that's it
I think listen the cue forest cue force
loaded down right
you got got you got video game releases
you got Thanksgiving right before Bob's
birthday is in that time of the year so
it's really busy I think we should
spread out I think if we put Christmas
well take out my birthday can I have
cute you doesn't have a lot going on
when's your birthday and April
oh that yeah that's cute too yeah that's
okay there's something particularly
interesting in there you know right like
yeah cuz mark basically gets like July
4th all I gets Easter and like is Easter
even a real holiday we just run into the
exact same problem my problem is other
events getting in the way of the true
meaning of Christmas your birthday as we
all know is a huge celebration I think
that would just overshadow Christmas
it's not about what we get Wade it's
about what we give ok well I don't give
or get candy on Easter so is it real is
it really real about candy it's about
eggs
yeah it's about how bunnies make a lot
of sex no one ever gave me
I've never even eaten eggs on Easter but
what they're not chicken eggs they're
bunny eggs which are made of chocolate
and cream or peanut butter and doesn't
get together anymore for that ok you
know what that's one family drama this
isn't about your this isn't about your
family I I'm gonna go ahead and say okay
if Easter's got cute always where we
putting Christmas
he always steers it to be about himself
you know no no listen
there is about your family everything's
about you what is this yeah okay well
let's talk about March March isn't about
me in fact it's only month isn't Y is
March not even about me a little bit it
should be right you are so selfish you
are you know I'm not I just care about
me that's the definition of selfish no
no no selfish is like a bad way I I love
myself and wanted to be about me in a
good way I prefer the term confidence
I'm being self confident right now I
just I feel like I feel like he doesn't
get it I feel like both of you are not
being very productive
Wade selfish I don't think we're gonna
solve that problem you don't even wear
it the nice way to say selfish is
independent not self-confident you
dumbass Wow the Bahamas is hot I'm not
gonna wear a frickin wool coat in the
Bahamas obviously if we move Christmas
to Bahamas Day Christmas is on why would
you blow it if it was gonna be Christmas
why would it also be Bahamas Day
we got share you don't wanna be selfish
about it we could share movin Christmas
you don't want to share with Hanukkah Oh
who's being selfish now maybe we should
just be with Chanukah and have a
Chrismukkah it's honestly still mostly
you that's being selfish you're right
also I pitched Chris Monica last month
at the meeting okay
so ever I feel like you're just trying
to take my idea and weasel your way out
of your own selfishness I don't know
your idea but I vote for it I thought
all right I thought the idea was stupid
so I just said nothing in the hopes that
it would die out but you know now that
you said it wait it doesn't sound so bad
well yeah I think Chris Monica's a good
idea yeah I mean no no no no it sounds
like a good idea if you only like it
because it's his idea then you don't
even care that we're not approving a
measure this is why people take public
speaking courses cuz it matters how you
pitch things he pitched it well he
brought I I see the strategy he it's a
standard sales pitch he he negged me he
made me angry at him and then he offered
something to look forward to so that's
that's kudos to you it's a classic sales
pitch it's called the selfish and then
solution it's the SS way it's what all
right like the SS like the Titanic the
SS Titanic Titanic good save is that
Soviet thing or Nazi thing you know just
keep saying keep guessing yeah keep
guessing that good way to do it
maybe we should just go with Chris
Monica and forget about the other parts
like what part would you like Hana miss
better Hana miss or Chris Monica I
actually kind of like harmless yeah
pretty cool you know you got some good
ideas but also you got some ideas that
make me suspect things about you well
it's fair to suspect things they're
probably true but that's that's
irrelevant
let's just celebrate Hanabusa okay so
who's who's on slay duty this year well
I guess we got a volunteer over there
you do it all wrong alright it's alright
everyone let me just get this out of
here real quick hang out okay hands down
does anyone else want to volunteer for
slay duty this year I mean I mean if
we're just gonna have no one else are
you pointing at no I'm not pointing I'm
pointing to the one person that matters
but also you know I'm pointing
volunteering myself that lives above the
gymnasium that we meet in yeah I mean
not many people know but he's also the
landlord is I didn't know that yeah
we're right you'd never suspect but he
always sees me you don't breaking rules
you don't you don't think about things
like that no what do you have dramatic
hand gesture look at me with those eyes
look at me with those dirty eyes
it's a you're pouring you're pouring one
out for your homies you're pouring tea
into it yeah what - is there there's a
yeah two words okay cool right first
word like it sounds like sounds like
liquid here
jerking wanking almost there
yeah I'll finish you off later no
nothing
blank stare oh I'll finish you into
words
yeah finish you off later that's it I'll
finish you off I may have been
forgetting to hold V again yeah I think
we figured that out like the only
seconds to go okay I'm sorry
so um I'll finish you off later mark
you're in drive to slay my heart
that's a weird that was a weird thing
other weird what a big nice what nights
come is nights come is a night holy
welcome whoa matches and now botton okay
oh god the opponent scandal sometimes me
a squirt gun some tells me it's not this
is not what I expected the game to be
with the dark creepy atmosphere yeah
yeah odd about this it's pretty normal I
don't know what you're on about
okay so I'm just aiming for the candle
right oh here we go again
already in squirt mode well it doesn't
take much to get me there my squirt knee
Bob my close to your candle oh god damn
it
well they're in my spring am i yeah you
are
my spring anywhere near marks candle hey
let's leave my candle oh it's a tough
grab oh god oh god I'm at irony what
your candle I'm trying what's happening
behind
oh my god it's gone okay bye mark mark
is it really you I'm trying I'm trying
to send Bob Bob's trying to send me back
[Music]
you ready for this action
oh good job everybody
I'm making gang signs over here yet wait
my candle went out it's so dark how am I
supposed to light a match it when it's
so dark it's dark I'm getting closer
Mead
oh you're so dead closer hang on I
definitely have this oh hey what's the
match yeah I did like the match
[Music]
all right what did my my my candle go
out scary I went when you guys were
saying there was something behind you
died in the best position ever look look
at your sprawled out all can its oh yeah
okay that's pretty good again to be
labeled as one of the only ones that's
fun yeah alright this time you guys are
going down I'm a different strategy
yeah just keep just keep a match lit and
then oh yeah just get it right in there
cuz it's a dirty little spray what the
I mean you calm down wait what are
you talking about alright alright
strategy step one over here we go you're
done you're you're you're I got what
it's not spring it was spring well I had
it I had a perfect gun trigger finger oh
no don't use bread no use vine I've got
some spray okay I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
I will not I will not you you stop
living come on he's right there stop oh
and now it's not spraying anymore I
don't think spring its gonna do anything
cause II know what what are you not dead
do I feel fine can I block you from
spraying my candle oh I'm trying to
spray your kid you can try oh I'm out of
spray again come on this is like so all
over you oh wait oh you got the
strategies don't you oh you think you're
so clever you think you've won but I've
got another trick up my sleeve
also too as well mine sprayed on
spraying there we go fill it
no I gotta let go for longer oh wait I
need some light oh my match went out
this strategy really didn't pay off
oh oh all right this is fine oh we're
gonna get some like you got some light
you lit one you've got to it but I
wasn't holding it so it didn't really
help me okay lady yeah I don't know why
you got to survive
I don't maybe you know I think the ghost
owed me one I brought you guys here out
and he's not dead
yeah just squirting him and I'm gonna
try to squirt again just to see your
candle baby I don't want to squirt my
candle all right fine I'll squirt my
candle come on come on bud come on you
can do it bud that was good it's not
spraying anymore are you spraying with
one hand right now
yeah you yeah I've got I figured
out how to hold it right I'd probably be
good at the gun ones now wiggle it
waggle it it's not spraying it is oh
it's not hitting it okay cool oh I think
too low Oh see okay see I don't see how
this is fair now I think this is a bad
idea
um let's see if I can just spray a
little match here got it I think he
really believed in you mark I believe in
Austin all over the place so clumsy time
mark
good okay good but I got you listen to
him clearly you don't worship Satan as
well as I do yeah you're right Santa I
sure don't well this time I'm gonna show
you a thing or two about something so it
so it is possible to hold it in a way
yeah I just had to get my finger in
first and then the rest you guys are
done no no no no no no okay listen mercy
upon thy good soul I get your no no no
no I can't
yeah that's what you get that's what you
get did you get I just why can I not
grab a single goddamn match come on
Handel's not out already is it no I'm
just preparing I lost my gun okay all
right you guys are done zone now just
tried on light my candle I don't know
how to light this match I'm not just
whip it on some stuff try it how did
that happen what okay light light light
light light light light light - one got
it
I'm the best I don't like this baby
staring at me thank you you sprayed
yourself mash coming at ya all
right you didn't oh I tried I tried
no she won't take me we were to truce
yet have a truce it doesn't sound like
you have a truce to me it's a like a
weighty I love the way your hair looks
wait I have a match do you need a man
Oh laughing baby all right Bob how about
we just take my hand okay my hand I'm
trying how about we just call truce I
don't like this game wait what if I just
do this oh oh god mark yes look
here that's you give I got put it right
in my palm I try oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god is the baby laughed
every time like that that's just
concerned yeah I got this guy's I got
this okay maybe I don't
hey there we go problem solved
Bob you don't have to join us yes
when I jam on some matches
cursing in the afternoon
[Music]
hang on I can do this T I live in Tyre
I wouldn't been spared we helped I'll
Casey nice that wave at you and then
they beyond thank you goodbye my friend
[Music]
you